[Music]
the dealing with the dry forums brings
together keynote speakers one of whom is
a grain producer as well as a leading
local agronomist drew pendous II so my
main talk today was on staff and and
some of the impacts during a drought so
it's not only the business owners and
the farmers doing it tough during the
drought the the key thing that people
forget about is what your staff are
feeling as well because they're going
through similar issues you know they're
worried about their jobs and their
security same as the farmers are they're
worried about income and how they're
going to get through this dry period so
some of the big issues we we run into
with staff is keeping their enthusiasm
to the point where we you probably need
to involve your staff and some of the
decision making during the drive period
more than you have before just to keep
them abreast of what's going on some of
the things that a lot of people are
doing is there's a lot of infrastructure
then looked at with staffs a lot more
fencing a lot more soil works erosion
control stuff like that that they
normally don't put a lot of emphasis on
but to keep their staff on they're doing
those sort of things still a big cost to
the business but coming out of the
drought should make their decisions a
lot better if going forward having
making sure they've got good water
structures when spraying does start
again when it does rain they've got a
really good system in place so there's a
lot of funding for courses at the moment
which is free through rural assistance
and stuff like that so that's a really
good thing we're getting into but other
regions are doing similar things there's
been a few study to us some people went
over to India and a lot of gone to
America just doing study tours and going
on those sort of things one of the big
things we've done is making sure people
to koala days now out of their time take
the families away spend time with the
kids and all that sorting because we can
do it now we're not under a huge work
pressure and the hours of time and doing
those sort of things and I think that's
really key for mental health is to get
yeah your family won't they do something
different for a while
if you put stuff off during this hard
time what happens when it does break you
know they're going to be hard to find
stuff there's a lot of people moving to
this to the cities during this dry time
if they've been put off and I can't see
those people coming back so that's a big
consideration on every decision you make
and if you take the short-term view it
may come back and cause a lot of
problems going for but every farm is
different and everyone's got a different
situation and some farms there isn't
that there's no extra work a lot of
people are finding other jobs for their
staff with the equipment they got like
excavators and dozers and trucks and
stuff like that and they're finding
other jobs contracting work to do with
their staff or they're finding an
alternative jobs for periods of time
during this dry period so when it does
break they're still able to come back on
farm we can still do our management
decisions have good time one of the
other key things to remember is that you
know it's not on staff it's not just
yourself and the people working on the
farm but it's also the wives within the
business because they take a lot of
burden in this and quite often that oh I
see they get neglected in these period
of times or the husband brings home all
their troubles and no one gives those
considerations to the wives because
they're taking that burden just as much
as everyone else and to the point where
some of the kids are going back to
school and they're worried that their
father and mother are struggling and
they're going home and they're taking
that back to their schooling
so this is the worst drought we've
actually seen in history in this region
but yeah just be prepared it's probably
the key to getting through this and we
will we will get through it because
we're resilient and with our it's this
it's the way we are go to the
description bar below for the latest
information links and resources